hello and welcome to the tensor flow
object detection API tutorial in this
video I will walk you through the
tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started
this part is basically your importing
all the libraries we need a lot of these
libraries for example numpy we need
image io date/time and ill and so on and
so forth and of course matplotlib so we
import all these libraries and then
there are a bunch of variables which
have some parts for the files and
folders so this is regular stuff let's
keep moving
then we import the matplotlib and make
it inline and a few more imports all
right then these are some warnings we
can just ignore them so if I run this
code once again it will go away right
and then here on once we do the model
preparation and what we are going to do
is we are going to use an existing
neural network model so we are not going
to chain a new one because that really
will take a long time and needs a lot of
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there are already
modules that have been trained and in
this case it is the SSD with mobile net
this model that we are going to use and
this model is trained to detect objects
and it is readily available as open
source so we can actually use this and
if you want to use other models there
are a few more models available so you
can click on this link here and let me
just take you there there are few more
models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models ok so we will be
using that model so this piece of code
this line is basically importing that
model and this
also known as frozen model the term we
uses frozen model so we import download
and import that and then we will
actually use that model in our code
thank you so these two cells we have
downloaded and imported the model and
then once it is available locally we
could then load this into our program
all right so we loading this into memory
and they you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to do map the numbers to text as
you may be aware when we actually build
the model and when we run predictions
the model will not give a text the
output of the model is usually a number
so we need to map that to a text so for
example if the network predicts that the
output is 5 we know that 5 means it is
an aeroplane but things like that so
this mapping is done in just next cell
all right so let's keep moving and then
we have a helper code which will
basically load the data or to load the
images and transform into numpy RS this
is also used in doing object detection
in images so we are actually going to
reuse because video is nothing but
consists of frames which in turn are
images so we are going to pretty much
use the reuse the same code which we
used for doing object detection in
images so this is where the actual
detection starts so here this is the
path or where the images are stored so
this is here once again we are reusing
the code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the images were stored and this is
the extension and this was done for
about 2 or 3 images so we're going to
continue to use this and we go down I'll
skip this section so this is the cell
where we are actually loading the video
and converting it into frames and then
using frame by frame we are detecting
the objects in the image so in this code
what we are doing basically is the few
lines of code what they do is basically
one
they find an object a box will be drawn
around those each of those objects and
the input file the name of the input
video file is traffic it is the
extension is mp4 and we have this video
reader so excellent object which is
basically art of this class called image
IO so we can read and write videos using
that and the video that we are going to
use as traffic dot mp4 you can use any
mp4 file but in our case I picked up
video which has like car so let me just
show you so this is in this object
detection folder I have this mp4 file
I'll just quickly play this video it's a
little slow yeah okay so here we go this
is the video it's a short one relatively
small video so that for this particular
demo and what it will do is once we run
our color it will detect each of these
cars and it will annotate them as cars
so in this particular video we only have
cars we can later on see with another
video I think I have cat here so we can
also try it at that but lets us check
with this traffic video so let me go
back so we will be reading this frame by
frame and no actually we will be reading
the video file but then we will be
analyzing it frame by frame and we will
be reading them at 10 frames per second
that is the rate we are mentioning here
and analyzing it and then annotating and
then writing it back so you will see
that we will have a video file name
something like this traffic underscore
annotated and we will see the annotated
video so let's go back and run through
this piece of code and then we will come
back and see the annotated term video
this might take a little while so I will
pause the video after running this
particular cell and then come back to
show you the results
alright so let's go ahead and run it so
it is running now and it is also
important that at the end you close the
video writer so that it is similar to a
file pointer when you open a file you
should also make sure you
close it so that it doesn't harm the
resources so it's very similar at the
end of it the last piece or last line of
code should be video underscore writer
dot close all right so I'll pause and
then I'll come back okay
so we'll see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here and the
processing is done the hourglass is
disappeared
that means the video has been processed
so let's go back and check the annotated
video we'll go back to my file manager
so this was the original traffic dot mp4
and now you are out here traffic
underscore annotated and before so let's
go and run this and see how it looks you
see here does got each of these cars are
getting detected let me pause and show
you so we pause here it says car 70% let
us allow it to go a little further it
detects something on top what is that
truck okay
so I think because of the board on top
it somehow thinks there is a truck let's
lay it some more and see if it detects
anything else so this is again a car
looks like so let us yeah so this is a
car and it has confidence level of 69
percent okay this is again a car alright
so basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving the
little slowly and our application will
our network will detect that this is a
cat and even when the cat moves a little
bit in the other direction it'll
continue to detect and show that it is a
cat okay so yeah so this is our original
video is let's go ahead and change our
code to analyze this one and see if it
detects our network detects this cat
close this here we go and go back to my
code all we need to do is change this
traffic to get the extension it will
automatically pick up because it is
given here and then
we'll run through so very quickly once
again what it is doing is this video
reader video underscore reader has a
neat little feature or interface whereby
you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you are in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this alright so now let's once again run
just this cell rest of the stuff remains
the same so I will run the cell again it
will take a little while so the our
classes come back I will pause and then
come back in a little while alright so
the processing is done let's go and
check the annotated video so here so we
have cat annotated during this one let's
play this alright so you can see here
just detecting the cat and in the
beginning you also saw it detected
something else the other looks like a
detected one more object so let's just
go back and see what it has detected
here let's see yes so what is it trying
to show here it's too small not able to
see but it is trying to detect something
I think it is saying there's a car I
don't know
alright okay so in this video there is
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and let's wait for some time
and see if it continues to detect it
when the cat turns around and moves as
well just in a little bit that's going
to happen and we will see there we go
and in spite of turning the other way
I think our network is able to detect
that it is a cat so let me freeze and
then show here this actually still
continues to detect it as a cat alright
so that's pretty much it I think that's
the only object that it detects in this
particular video ok so close this so
that's pretty much it thank you very
much for watching this video you have a
great day and in case you have any
questions please put them below the
video here and we will be more than
happy to get back to you and make sure
you put your email id so that we can
contact you in case
you have any questions thank you once
again bye-bye hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified
click here